[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele beobachter sind der ansicht ungarn
notiere immer mehr zu so was wie eine
kalorienarme version russlands und damit
meine ich nicht die absenz
energiereicher rohstoffe natürlich gibt
es in ungarn keinen dermaßen hohen grad
an systemischer korruption wie in
russland und der autoritarismus der
regierung orban ist noch welten von den
putins entfernt aber der hat ja auch mal
klein angefangen und victor bahn macht
schon ziemlich deutlich wer sein großes
idol ist die tendenz ist klar auch wenn
obamas politische gegner derzeit noch
relativ sicher tee trinken oder sich in
der nähe von fenstern aufhalten können
schließlich ist ungarn noch immer ein
mitglied der europäischen union das
heißt es gibt dort zumindest ein
grundlegendes niveau demokratische
rechtsstaatliche garantien über eines
müssen uns jedoch klar sein mit der
eurobahn der langjährige
ministerpräsident ungarns ist in europa
einer der wichtigsten verbündeten des
terrorpaten putin zur zeit der einzige
staatschef der dies auch offen zu
erkennen gibt gut in brüssel war er
schon lange das enfant terrible
schlechthin ultrakonservativ autoritär
ein verehrer putins und dass er
weiterhin zu seinem kumpel im kreml hält
auch nachdem dieser sein wahres gesicht
endgültig offen gezeigt hat ist den
übrigen politiker es in der eu nur bei
oberflächlicher betrachtung peinlich
[Musik]
in wahrheit stellt waren für sie eine
willkommene ablenkung vom eigenen
moralischen versagen und strategischen
dilemma dar da zeigen dann sogar auch
mal leute aus der engsten schüler
connection gerne scheinheilig mit dem
finger auf das ungarische dschungelkind
mit dem sie doch im gleichen sandkasten
gespielt haben das jedoch noch blut
beschmierte hände hat und sich dafür
hallo noch nicht mal offiziell stimmt
und ich weiß dass uns wieder ein paar
putin zombies in den kommentaren
beschuldigen werden von george soros
finanziert zu werden denn jeder weiß
dass orban der ewige erzfeind von voraus
ist es ist also glasklar dieses video
wird sicherlich von schorsch finanziert
damit wir den ehrenwerten ungarischen
ministerpräsidenten in den dreck ziehen
aber so leid es mir tut euch enttäuschen
zu müssen im heutigen video werden wir
uns ganz sachlich mit bestimmten
aspekten von ordnungspolitik
beschäftigen die euch wahrscheinlich
ziemlich überraschend werden ja er
wertet durchaus positive facetten des
ungarischen ministerpräsidenten kennen
lernen sogar solche von denen sich
westliche politiker ruhig mal eine
scheibe abschneiden könnten denn nur so
werdet ihr verstehen warum europa ein
faktor ist mit dem europa auch in
zukunft gerechnet werden muss ob wir
dies nun mögen oder nicht also in diesem
video könnt ihr keine plumpes orban
bashing erwarten wie es vielleicht gerne
hätte denn um eines klarzustellen die
feinde unserer feinde sind nicht
automatisch unsere freunde jede art von
realpolitik hat ihre grenzen und bei
orange orange stößt man ganz sicher an
diese übrigens hat er schon mal gefragt
warum wird eigentlich so bekannt ist nun
am ende dieses videos verraten wir euch
jetzt konzentrieren wir uns jedoch
lieber auf eine andere seite ungarns
schauen wir uns mal die folgende
schlagzeile an
ungarische ministerpräsident viktor
orban gewinnt vierte amtszeit in folge
das ist schon beachtlich hier wahlsiege
in folge viktor orban ist seit mehr als
zwölf jahren an der macht und jedes mal
wenn er sich den umgangs verwahrt stellt
räumt der studierte jurist ordentlich ab
[Musik]
und die letzten wahlen anfang april 2022
haben es wahrlich in sich denn in diesem
fall hatten sich fast alle anderen
politischen parteien zu einer koalition
zusammengeschlossen um ihn zu besiegen
sie wollten es der demokratischen
opposition in tschechien gleich tun die
mit dieser strategie den populistischen
ex stasi em andré habisch geschlagen
hatte doch anders als in prag schlug der
wechsel in budapest orban hat nicht nur
gewonnen er hat nicht nur wieder mit
absoluter mehrheit gewonnen nein er hat
sogar mit dem höchsten anteil an
wählerstimmen gewonnen den eine parteien
und ungarn seit dem fall des kommunismus
im jahr 1989 erzielen konnte vollkommen
zu recht verhöhnte er seine gegner im in
und ausland daher mit dem durchaus
geistreichen spruch sein sieg sei so
groß dass man ihn nicht nur vom mond
aussehen können sondern sogar von
brüssel aus
einen seitenhieb der absolut und sehr
schmerzhaft ins schwarze traf so witzig
war putin früher auch mal aber wie wir
bereits gesagt haben wird ungarn immer
mehr zu einer diversion russlands das
bedeutet dass die wahlen relativ frei
sind ja stimmt dass orban partei fidesz
hier und da ein wenig geschummelt hat
aber waren laufen nirgendwo sauber und
man muss die realität als das erkennen
was sie nun mann ist das wahlergebnis
bild den gemütszustand der ungarn ab
orban hat es einfach nicht nötig weil
massiv zu fälschen er ist in seinem land
sehr beliebt daher werden wir uns der
frage wird man warum eigentlich was ist
das geheimnis hinter dem erfolg viktor
orban gibt es eine lektion die wir von
ungarn lernen können und warum verdammt
noch mal ist sein erster george orosz
auf der ganzen welt so bekannt heute
werden wir nicht nur all diese fragen
beantworten sondern euch auch mental
darauf vorbereiten dass so etwas
ungemütlich und zwiespältige thema
ungarn und george orosz noch ein
weiteres video bringen werden im gt auf
fragen eingehen die wir in diesem video
nicht behandeln können unserer meinung
nach wird dieses komplexe thema in der
regel nicht nur sehr plakativ und
polarisierend behandelt sondern seine
bedeutung wird ganz europa weitgehend
unterschätzt ich würde euch an dieser
stelle da auch gerne bitten nicht zu
vergessen dass wir bei unserer arbeit
auf eure unterstützung angewiesen sind
da und schorsch gebe nicht finanziert
ich meine natürlich könnte auch er den
paypal spenden link in der beschreibung
unter dem video nutzen dies würde unsere
meinung und die aussage in unseren
videos jedoch kein bisschen beeinflussen
tja pech gehabt denn dank unserer treuen
zuschauer bleiben wir unabhängig
[Musik]
es geht um die wirtschaft bvdw ev
kennst du ein programm namens akika wenn
du im bereich architektur arbeit ist
hast du es vielleicht schon einmal
benutzt wenn es ist eines der
wichtigsten software produkte auf diesem
gebiet und es wurde in ungarn entwickelt
anhand dieses beispiel ist kannst du dir
ein bild davon machen dass die
ungarische wirtschaft viel potenzial hat
das land hat eine beachtliche it und
automobil industrie einen bedeutenden
pharmasektor und jede menge weiterer
verarbeitender wirtschaft mit einem sehr
hohen wertschöpfungs grad
mit anderen worten es ist kein reiches
land wie deutschland oder schweden aber
es ist eine der erfolgreichsten
postkommunistischen volkswirtschaften
auch wenn es das niveau tschechiens und
polens nicht erreichen kann als orban an
die macht kam war die situation jedoch
ganz anders darin befand sich damals in
einer schweren wirtschaftskrise
man schrieb das jahr 2010 und ungarn war
eines der länder die am stärksten von
der großen finanzkrise betroffen waren
das land hat er elf prozent
arbeitslosigkeit neben spanien die
höchste quote in europa und ein großes
defizit von 7 prozent eine zahl die weit
über den europäischen anforderungen lag
es schien als hätte man eine menge
arbeit vor sich
und was war sein rezept zur rettung der
ungarischen wirtschaft nun man könnte
sagen dass orban das gegenteil dessen
getan hat was jede mitte-links-regierung
tun würde wir müssen es an dieser stelle
deutlich sagen orban ist ultra
nationalistische und marc menschen die
aus dem ausland kommen nicht so
supertoll leiden aber wenn es um geld
geht ändert sich sein tonfall komplett
im grunde hat orban strategie 2 sollen
die reduzierung der öffentlichen
ausgaben und das ausrollen des roten
teppichs für ausländisches kapital oder
in dieser hinsicht ist ungarn
tatsächlich eine echte erfolgsgeschichte
wird mal einen blick auf diese grafik
[Musik]
wenn ihr genau hinsieht werdet ihr
feststellen dass ungarn mehr geld aus
dem ausland anziehen kann als länder wie
deutschland oder polen fast 75 prozent
der investitionen industrie des landes
kommen aus dem ausland und es ist kein
zufall dass das land seinen höchsten
stand erreicht hat nach dem aufwand an
die macht gekommen war die frage lautet
daher was hat das ungarn orbáns was
andere länder nicht haben nun die erste
antwort sind niedrige steuern wenn wir
an ländern mit niedrigen steuersätzen
denken kommt uns irland oder luxemburg
den sind aber die wahrheit ist dass
ungarn den niedrigsten
körperschaftsteuersatz in europa hat
doch mal einen blick auf diese karte
seit 2017 zahlen ungarische unternehmen
eine basis körperschaftsteuer von nur 9
prozent dazu kommen noch alle möglichen
subventionsprogramme und steuerabzüge
wenn ein unternehmen zum beispiel seite
gewinnen ungarische start-ups investiert
kann es bis zu 80 prozent steuern sparen
wenn man dann noch bedenkt dass ungarn
über gut ausgebildete arbeitskräfte und
relativ niedrige löhne verfügt ist es
leicht zu verstehen warum dieses land
immer wieder geld aus dem ausland
anzieht damit ihr einen eindruck bekommt
wovon hier die rede ist ungarn ist die
nummer zwei in der gesamten europäischen
union wenn es darum geht investitionen
aus südkorea anzuziehen das bedeutet
nicht dass südkorea der hauptinvestor
ist ganz im gegenteil aber ist die als
beispiel dafür dass unternehmen aus floh
weit entfernten ländern dies mit korea
ihr geht lieber auf ungarn setzen als
auf andere länder
anders ausgedrückt ja eurobahn markt das
schwarze schaf der europäischen familie
sein aber die wirtschaftlichen
ergebnisse in der politik sind gar nicht
so schlecht er mag ein mann sein dekret
attenberg zum weinen bringen würde aber
wenn unternehmen die elektroautos
herstellen ein standort für ihre
fabriken wählen ziehen sie ungarn vielen
anderen ländern vor ganz genau ab 2021
konnte sich ungarn an die spitze der
europäischen elektrofahrzeug industrie
setzen ihr glaubt mir nicht dann sehe
ich mal folgendes an sk innovation baut
dritte batteriefabrik in ungarn bmw baut
eine eine milliarde euro elektroauto
fabrik in ungarn
mercedes benz will in ungarn die
serienproduktion eines reinen
elektrofahrzeug starten und ich weiß
dass einige von euch jetzt denken nun ja
ungarn mag ein paradies für unternehmen
seien aber kommt all dieses geld
wirklich in den taschen der einfachen
ungarn an nun auch hier sprechen die
daten für sich im vergleich im jahr 2010
lag die arbeitslosenquote in spanien bei
19 prozent in ungarn bei 11% zehn jahre
später im jahr 2020 lag die quote in
spanien noch immer beiliegenden 15
prozent in ungarn jedoch ist sie auf
knapp über vier prozent gefallen all
dieses wirtschaftswachstum hat mehr geld
für den staat und einem gesünderen
haushalt geführt und wofür wurde dieses
geld ausgegeben wie funktioniert die
sozialpolitik von orban genau das werden
wir uns jetzt ansehe
familien werde
ich weiß dass viele von euch denken
viktor orban ist nichts anderes als ein
rechtspopulist seine gesamte
wirtschaftspolitik besteht darin die
steuern zu senken wie sowas könnte jeder
trottel die bürger bei laune halten die
wahrheit ist jedoch dass eine
reduzierung eurobahn es auch die
populistischen facetten seiner politik
weder gerecht noch zielführend wäre er
ist mehr als das viel mehr denn wenn wir
die ungarische steuer politik in
irgendeiner weise ein ordner müssten
dann kann man sie nur als er einen anti
populismus bezeichnen ja es stimmt die
unternehmen zahlen weniger steuern als
in jedem anderen europäischen land aber
vergesst nicht dass unternehmen nicht
wählen können in ungarn fällt fast die
gesamte steuerlast auf den
durchschnittsbürger und zwar mit der
unpopulärsten steuer die es gibt der
mehrwertsteuer und jeder menge andere
indirekter steuern ja ungarn hast dich
niedrigsten unternehmenssteuern europa
aber was die indirekten steuern angeht
stoßen wir auf das gegenteil 27 prozent
ja ich mache keine witze während die
meisten europäischen länder
mehrwertsteuersätze zwischen 1921
prozent haben liegt dieser in ungarn bei
satten 27 prozent man kann diese politik
kritisieren aber wir können sich ja
nicht sagen dass sie ein versuch
darstellen würde wähler zu kaufen ganz
im gegenteil
und die frage ist natürlich wohin all
das geld geht welches sozialpolitik gibt
es in ungarn nun hier können wir von
einer art konservativer sozialdemokratie
sprechen klingt überraschend ist aber so
denn hier zeigt sich orban von seiner
traditionellsten und gleichzeitig
nachhaltigsten sozialsten und am
stärksten zukunftsorientierten seite
denn fast alles sozialpolitischen maßen
ansehen auf ein einziges ziel
ausgerichtet dass die organe mehr kinder
zur welt bringen
ja ihr habt euch nicht verhör viktor
orban hat nicht begriffen was das
zukunfts problem nummer eins der
entwickelten welt ist er ist auch einer
der wenigen die es wirklich angeht die
renten krise ist in ganz europa ein
großes problem auch in ungarn und thomas
rasset um den demografischen rückgang zu
vermeiden basiert darauf die ungarn mit
allen mitteln dazu zu bringen kinder zu
bekommen zb ist ein familien mit vier
oder mehr kindern seit 2012 keine
einkommenssteuer mehr ja das stimmt
einfach so 0 prozent einkommensteuer
aber nicht nur dass mindestens vier
kinder zur welt gebracht haben sind ganz
steuerfrei ein leben lang aber auch
familien mit weniger als vier kindern
gehen nicht leer aus sondern werden vom
staat gefördert und unterstützt und zwar
genau bei den ausgaben welche familien
mit kindern am stärksten belasten zum
beispiel können familien mit drei bis
vier kindern die einen verkaufen einen
zuschuss von rund 7000 euro erhalten
es geht darum den menschen nicht nur
jegliche angst vor dem finanziellen
abstieg durch die gründung einer familie
zu nehmen sondern ihre einstellung zu
kindern komplett ins positive zu drehen
kinder sollen wieder als faktor des
wohlstands und des sozialen status
wahrgenommen werden nicht mehr als
belastung risiko und bedrohung des
eigenen gemütlichen lebensstils mit
anderen worten die politik obamas ist
extrem sozial wirklich sozial nachhaltig
und zukunftsorientiert sozial ja stimmt
dass es sich um sozialleistungen handelt
die an das kinderkriegen gebunden sind
aber es ist eine hilfe deren früchte
schließlich alle ungarn erreichen wird
egal ob rentner oder renten
beitragszahler und glaubt nicht eine
sekunde daran dass es nicht um reine
symbolpolitik ahnen würde wie man sich
aus anderen aussterbenden ländern in
europa gewohnt ist vorband kleckert hier
kein bisschen er klotzt ordentlich im
jahr 2019 macht die sogenannten familien
schutzprogramme 4,8 prozent des gesamten
ungarischen bip aus tendenz steigend das
ist doch mal wirklich ein wort und die
frage die ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
stellen werde lautet funktioniert diese
politik wirklich gelingt ist ungarn
wirklich dass demografischen schwarze
loch zu schließen nun hier kommt leider
nächste block west wenn die antwort
lautet nein
schaut euch diese grafik an
hier könnt ihr sehen wie die
fruchtbarkeitsrate in ungarn mit oder
ohne familienförderung ungefähr gleich
bleibt ungarische frauen bekommen im
durchschnitt 1,6 kinder die ungarische
bevölkerung nimmt weiter ab zwar konnten
die ungarn das allzeittief aus dem jahr
2011 mittlerweile überwinden allerdings
ist diese entwicklung auch in den
umliegenden ländern zu beobachten
natürlich der sich dabei einerseits die
frage wäre umgangen oder die
familienförderung noch schlechter
gefahren andererseits muss man sich
jedoch auch fragen welche faktoren
fielen um garantien mit die
geburtenziffern hochgeht und hier muss
man ganz einfach feststellen die
finanzielle absicherung kinderreiche
familien von staatlicher seite ist
sicherlich eine notwendige bedingung
aber keine hinreichende und auf all die
vielen anderen faktoren welche die
fertilitätsrate unter das der
produktions niveau drücken hat auch
orban keine lösung parat dieses thema
erachten wir als derart weitreichenden
bedeutet für unser aller zukunft dass
wir ihn noch viele weitere videos widmen
werden heute konzentrieren wir uns aber
auf das ungarische szenario denn auch
wenn die ungarn ihre fertilität noch
nicht ausreichend mussten konnten die
familienförderung hat einen anderen
effekt durchaus beachtenswert ist denn
wenn es um die verringerung der
ungleichheit geht an orban ein genie zu
sein seht euch mal diese grafik an
[Musik]
hier könnt ihr sehen dass die kluft
zwischen arm und reich hin und ganz viel
sanfter verläuft als in frankreich oder
deutschland denn erwartet wird dass
sozialpolitik genau jenen die mit der
unterstützung und meistens in die
zukunft ihrer gesellschaft tun können
und ihr wisst wie wenig wir für sei der
autoritäre art seine missachtung der
medienfreiheit seine angriffe auf die
unabhängigkeit der justiz oder seine
zuneigung zu portieren star sie mögen
aber über diese positive fast hätte der
ungarischen politik wird leider viel zu
wenig gesprochen
[Musik]
bestimmt werden war nie bei einer gay
pride parade sein rhetorik ist weit von
dem entfernt was man in anderen ländern
als dass sozialpolitik verstehen würde
aber niemand kann leugnen dass seine
regierung ihr bestes tut um den am
meisten benachteiligten familien zu
helfen und das zeigt sich auch bei den
wahlen ja jetzt werden vielleicht einige
denken das visual politik orban auf ein
podest stellt könnte es sein dass eben
nicht schwarz sondern die ungarische
regierung uns unter der hand bezahlt nur
keine panik denn jetzt werden wir auch
über die andere seite ansprechen aber
achtung über eine seite die weder in den
ungarischen medien noch in den
westlichen mainstream medien erwähnt
wird also aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der mann der george soros erschoss
orange ist so etwas wie der elvis
presley der verschwörungstheorien es
gibt einfach keine in der schorsch nicht
irgendwo irgendwann auftaucht und höchst
wahrscheinlich hat jeder von euch schon
einmal aus einer dieser netten
geschichten von ihm gehört die frage ist
allerdings warum ist er eigentlich so
berührt lasst mich das erklären george
soros ist ein milliardär mit viel
politischem einfluss das ist wahr aber
er ist wieder der reichste mensch der
welt noch der einflussreichste warum
aber kennt dann jeder schorsch und nicht
zb die wesentliche reicheren und
politischen mächtigeren koch brüder nun
eine der wichtigsten antworten auf diese
frage sind wir bei viktor orban oder
besser gesagt bei jenen politischen
strategen der den mythos viktor orban
geschaffen hat aber was hat dieser gute
mann mit orban oder georges zu tun nun
europas politische karriere hat zwei
unterschiedliche phasen von 1998 bis
2002 war viktor orban premierminister
von ungarn und er sah damals nicht nur
ganz anders und viel besser aus als
heute nein man konnte man damals als ein
politiker charakterisieren der für
freiheitliche werte stand aber auch
sozial eingestellt war im jahr 2002
verlor er jedoch die wahlen acht jahre
lang versorgte er auf der
oppositionsbank oder in dieser zeit
hatte er aber finkel stina nada finkel
stil war ein politischer
kommunikationsberater aus den
vereinigten staaten oder besser gesagt
das trio adolf winkels team karoff und
liefert water sind so etwas wie frank
sinatra dean martin und sammy davis
junior
politischen beratung wahre genies ihrer
kunst und bei dieser kunst gibt es nur
eines wahlen zu gewinnen
[Musik]
und denkt es den machte sich sogleich
ans werk er erkannte als erstes das ohr
ganz image komplett umgekrempelt werden
muss wenn dieser auf einen grünen zweig
kommen will das neue bild urbans das
linkes die nun zeichnete war ganz klar
ein mann des volkes der seinem
wochenenden auf dem land verbringt und
pálinka trägt das aber war erst der
anfang denn finkes team wusste um in der
politik einen echten helden der sein
volk beschützt zu erschaffen muss erst
mal ein richtig fieser schurter herr der
dieses bedroht und gegen den
verhältnissen kann und wer war dieser
perfekte schurke für orban kein anderer
als george soros bei dieser stelle
wollen wir nicht werden was schon alles
in seinem leben getan hat und was er
jetzt tut das sparen wir uns für ein
separates video auf heute geht es nur um
die legendäre ikonische männer
beziehungen zwischen den machtmenschen
orban und schorsch der schorsch passt
der in funkels dienstplan wie die faust
aufs auge er war zwar bei weitem nicht
der reichste investor der welt aber
immerhin war ein milliardär wurde in
ungarn geboren und er war ein spekulant
das perfekte hassobjekt eine wahl kommt
waffe die so alt ist wie das unmögliche
versprechen case nun kommt das eher euro
waren schon immer kritisch
gegenüberstand und dass er jude ist
womit man den historisch verwurzelten
antisemitischen eifer der eu führen kann
mit anderen worten schorsch war der
perfekte bösewicht und das erklärt dann
auch sagen wie diese
ungarns orban greift in seiner rede
feinde an die mit geld spekulieren orban
europa darf sich nicht dem schorsch
netzwerk beugen aber wie bereits
eingangs gesagt über george orosz und
den mythos der um ihn herum entstanden
ist werden wir bald ein extra video
veröffentlicht indem wir dieses thema
ausführlich diskutieren werden kommen
wir zurück zur bahn denn es gibt noch
ein weiteres ass im ärmel hält eine
weitere spezial waffe um wahlen zu
gewinnen
ausserhalb ungarns leben mehr als 2,4
millionen ethnische ungarn odermatt
jahren dh in rumänien die slowakei
serbien der ukraine österreich kroatien
und slowenien gibt es viele ungarisch
sprachige community konnte seit jahren
gibt eurobahn fleißig ungarische pässe
an all diese unbeständigen bürger
anderer nationen aus damit sie an wahlen
in ungarn teilnehmen können
und die meisten von ihnen stimmen
regelmäßig und mit überwältigender
mehrheit für orders partei die vieles
war an dieser stelle werdet ihr euch
sicher fragen handelt es sich hierbei um
wahlmanipulation nun ja und nein es war
unfair erscheinen dass jemand über die
regierung eines anderen landes bestimmen
kann als in den er lebt nur weil der opa
eine bestimmte abstammung hatte
schließlich bekommen diese wähler ja
kaum irgendetwas vor den auswirkungen
ihrer wahl zu spüren kaum ein gesetz
dass aufgrund ihrer wahl erlassen wird
über steuern das rechtswesen
arbeitsrecht familienrecht meinungs- und
pressefreiheit oder was auch immer muss
die tangieren dass ihr das rechtssystem
ihres wohn landes in anspruch nehmen
können diese auslands wähler können also
quasi über die köpfe der iran lebenden
menschen hinweg bestimmen unter welchen
bedingungen letztere leben müssen und
von welchen politiker sie regiert werden
ohne selbst davon betroffen zu sein ein
weiteres problem ist natürlich dass sie
dadurch eine doppelte
staatsangehörigkeit bekommen und in zwei
ländern wählen können sowie zumeist auch
noch ein doppeltes wahlrecht für das
europaparlament haben die
ungerechtigkeiten gegenüber anderen wlan
sind also zahlreich andererseits wird
dieses wahlrechtlichen schlupfloch
jedoch überall als notwendiges übel der
demokratie betrachtet es wird
tatsächlich von sehr vielen politikern
verschiedenen länder ausgenutzt ein
prominentes beispiel ist zb der
türkische präsident erdogan der sich
eigentlich nur dank der stimmen von
außen an der macht halten kann hätten
nur die in der türkei die den menschen
das sagen wäre er längst weg vom fenster
und würde wohl wegen seiner zahlreichen
korruptionsaffären vor gericht gestellt
er in deutschland wiederum wurde oft
dass instrumente einwanderung benutzt um
der eigenen partei weder zu spielen das
betrifft zum beispiel die großzügigen
regelungen der richtigen kohl für
spätaussiedler da klar war dass diese
nach ihrer ankunft in deutschland
mehrheitlich cdu csu wählen würden
ähnlich spekulierte die spd auf das
kreuzchen auf den wahlscheinen
eingebürgerte doppelpass türken und so
weiter und so fort beispiele dafür
finden sich überall zb auch in den usa
wo die demokraten die einwanderung
continental allerdings bevorzuge die
republikaner hingegen die ihnen teuer
kubaner diese masche gab es also schon
immer allerdings muss man natürlich die
tatsache beachten dass sie sich in
ungarn besonders stark auswirkt denn 24
millionen auslands fehler stellen bei 10
millionen inlands bevölkerung schon
einen so hohen anteil da das eine
erhebliche verzerrung möglich ist und
niemand kann leugnen dass fordern nicht
nur seine wähler sehr gut kennt sondern
auch zu jeder schandtat bereit ist in
einer zeit in der der krieg in der
ukraine in aller munde zu sein scheint
hat eurobahn zum beispiel ein ebenso
riskanten die wahltaktischen richtigen
schachzug gemacht
und dann bricht mit der eu und ist
bereit für russisches gas in rubel zu
zahlen ganz genau umgang ist das eu-land
dass putins russland am nächsten steht
dabei ist die sogenannte neutralität
gegenüber dem mord terror regime nicht
nur aus ethischer sicht eine echte
schande sondern sendet durch die
ungarischen blockade der eu sanktionen
auch fatale signale an all jene schulden
die genau beobachten was sie sich
gegenüber der demokratischen welt
leisten können und was nicht orban
stellt sich ja klar außerhalb dieses
kulturkreises und ist somit die aktive
giftpille der europäischen demokratien
steht also den roten bullen schuld und
makro mit ihrem unterschwelligen perfekt
ist und opportunismus als böser bulle
hilfreich zur seite er ist sich noch
nicht mal zu schade aufgrund seiner
kremlnähe die langjährigen verbündeten
umgangs aus der wäsche radgruppe polen
tschechien und die slowakei über bord zu
werfen ja selbst holen dessen regierung
mit der man immer auf einer wellenlänge
war ist nun dafür ungarn in der eu
weiter zu isolieren aber im ungarn hat
der durchschnittliche wähler mit seinem
geldbeutel gestimmt und europas nähe zu
tieren bedeutet dass dort gas und öl
billiger sind als in jedem anderen
europäischen land zumindest auf kurze
sicht aber was könnte auf lange sicht
passieren nur hier kommt das große
problem der euronics ins spiel schon
seit jahren schluss budapest in größten
an seinen grenzen und seine haltung zur
ukraine krieg könnte der tropfen sein
der das fass zum überlaufen bringt
könnte die europäische union ungarn also
sanktionieren nun da sind wir doch mal
einen blick auf diese karte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn du dir das jahr 2004 ansicht ist
ein erheblicher sprung in der menge des
geldes das nach ungarn kommt zu erkennen
was also ist im jahr 2004 passiert nun
ganz genau ungar amt rat der
europäischen union bei den unternehmen
aus dem restlichen europa sind die
hauptinvestoren in ungarn mit anderen
worten obamas politischer und
wirtschaftlicher erfolg ist an die
europäische union gebunden die frage
lautet also was könnte passieren wenn
diese investitions hand plötzlich
zugedreht wird wie lange das man ist
europa noch erlauben sich die rosinen
sowohl aus dem russischen als auch aus
dem europäischen kuchen picken inwieweit
könnte ungarisch haltung zum ukraine
kriegt der anfang vom ende der ära orban
seien und welche meinung hat die
allgemein über den ungarischen dauer
regenten schreibt uns eure meinungen
dazu doch bitte in den kommentarbereich
wir sind schon sehr gespannt darauf ich
hoffe dass auch dieses video gefallen
hat oder vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt hat weil es ja gibt es mit einem
leitpfosten und sonntag es nicht aus
aber mit glöckchen um keines unserer
videos mehr so verpassen natürlich
wollen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
kleine spende von euch mit uns fällt
diese projekte weiterzuführen in paper
link dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
einem video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]